[Musique]
oui et non
first one
escargots
[Musique]
phoenix
et
[Musique]
salut tout le monde j'ai trouvé un truc
de dingue avec ça je peux me transformer
en tout les artistes des nrj music
awards c'est un truc de fou tu es prêt
watchbp r est bon je suis un gars quand
même
c'est quoi ça ah ouais mais là il ya
trop de cheveux c'est pas crédible aux
kings bon il est super beau gosse mais
un peu trop jeune quand même cet hommage
waouh je suis slimane bon j'aimerais
bien de witte a quand même et
je sais ce qui m'attend
non ça vient vite à quoi
ai je me kiffe habitat quand même
là c'est pas mal ça là on est pas mal je
crois
au nom pas bordas
et merde c'est qu'à ces
occasions